les a jamais testé sur le terrain
labourot satellitaire mais dans les rues
jamais à l'instant un projet du
département de la défense a subi une
attaque terroriste
dès lors c'est la cia qui prend le
commandement vous êtes couvert répliqué
on y va geisy chicago liaison satellite
la plus proche agression octobre at non
justifiés activé galva trop
transformer galles pas trop
[Musique]
montrons à ces aliens terroristes à quoi
ressemble à 983 stickers ou leur
direction dessine
[Musique]
cinq cibles en mouvement visuel correct
contact moins 3 km
200 m engagement transformation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
nous sommes bien en commande directe oui
en partie
charles-henri défaillant système cinq
cibles marquer
verrouillage missiles mise à feu
comprennent pas me dépêche
singer au contact
il fallut défaillance défaillante et
mayence ayant qu à le battre on a envoyé
plusieurs missions après l'autre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sans oublier
bonjour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
envoyé des équipes de secours victimes
civiles potentiel ils sont pris entre
deux feux je n'aime pas c'est une page
d'histoire pour votre pays pour le monde
la liberté de l'homme est en danger des
innocents meurent continuellement
tout ça
bon
là
faites le spa thrill doit pas lâcher
fait se battre vite vite
voilà
c'est ça
courte et sabha dans le sud
tu n'as pas rentable c'est pour ça que
je n'ai pas peur
[Applaudissements]
m
moi
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est c'est mon atout que
galva tron parti à lévis
[Musique]
à
mais la chercher
lalime pas là bas il va vous tuer besoin
de moi elle est cachée optimus je veux
pas sors de là tu me fais de la peine
prime tombe allégeance envers ces
humains l'inconvénient d'être fidèle à
une cause et que cette même cause finit
toujours par de traille qui a envoyé ici
quels sont tes origines après toi tu
crois être mais brême
non
tu as été fabriquées et et créateurs
seul de reprendre on travaille tous pour
quelqu'un
ça
c'est ça
pourquoi
[Musique]
la navette s'est arrêtée
ap
karakama
les autobots
à
[Musique]